habt ihr in letzter zeit auch den
eindruck gewonnen die us regierung würde
sich irgendwie schon riesig darauf
freuen dass russland endlich in die
ukraine einmarschiert was ja dann hört
jetzt gut zu
[Applaus]
[Musik]
moskau begann im märz 2021 damit truppen
panzer raketen und kriegsschiffe aus
allen militär bezirken des landes
zusammen zu ziehen und in massiver form
entlang der ukrainischen grenze zu
stationieren alles sollte nach einer
großen offensive aussehen der grund
angeblich um der wachsenden präsenz der
nato in der region entgegenzuwirken die
drohgebärde eines namen krieg spitzte
sich nun im februar 2022 immer weiter zu
und wurde sowohl von russland als auch
von den usa medial immer mehr eskaliert
auch wenn von seiten russlands zu es
kleine anzeichen der deeskalation zu
vernehmen sind aber was wenn das
ergebnis dieser operation genau das
gegenteil von den wäre was moskau
beabsichtigt hat liebe visual politik
zuschauer ich bin mir sicher dass sie
alle schon viel über den konflikt gehört
habe der sich in russland der ukraine
den usa und der europäischen union
zusammen gebraut aber vielleicht habt
ihr euch eine grundlegende frage noch
nicht gestellt könnte es nicht sein dass
sich die usa einen einmarsch russlands
in die ukraine geradezu herbeisehnen
nein ich versichere dir da haben nicht
den verstand verloren in diesem video
werfen wir einen blick auf vier wichtige
gründe warum der einmarsch in die
ukraine vor russland ein großer fehler
sein könnte eine große falle in die
wladimir putin tappen würde also passt
das gut auf und das gilt nicht nur für
dich wladimir wladimirowitsch
[Musik]
übrigens in einem der nächsten videos
werden sie euch von russland zurück und
erzählen auch langfristig über diese
krise hinausgehend vergisst also bitte
nicht wieso alle politik zu abonnieren
oder auch auf die kleine glocke zu
klicken falls ihr dieses thema genauso
interessant findet wie wir und jetzt
lasst uns loslegen
[Musik]
das wespennest namens ukraine
die republik ukraine ist nicht gerade
ein kleines land mit mehr als 600.000
quadratkilometer noch etwas 40 millionen
einwohnern wäre eine russische invasion
im großen stil enorm kostspielig und ich
beziehe mich nicht nur auf die kosten
der invasion selbst sondern vor allem
auf die kosten der besatzung lasst mich
dieses szenario kurz skizzieren alles
deute darauf hin dass die ukrainische
armee den russischen truppen nicht viel
entgegenzusetzen hat die mehr als
120.000 soldaten mit denen der creme die
ukraine umzingelt tat scheint in bezug
auf truppenzahl waffenarsenal kampfkraft
und kampferfahrung alles zu haben was
nötig ist um die mission erfolgreich zu
erfüllen
ihr habt eine ukrainische land armee die
viel besser geworden ist viel fähiger
aber die russen würden die luft und die
sie beherrschen philipp graf general der
us airforce in ruhestand aber wartet
einen moment denn auch in afghanistan
waren sowohl die sowjetunion als auch
die usa immer haushoch überlegen und
trotzdem fanden sich beide nach einer
gewissen zeit als gefangener in einem
nicht enden wollenden krieg wieder nun
so etwas könnte den russen auch in der
ukraine passieren
[Musik]
erstens könnte die invasion einen hohen
tribut und schwere verluste bei den
russischen truppen fordern vergisst
nicht dass sich die ukrainische armee
unter den regierungen prozent salewski
erheblich verbessert hat mehr als
400.000 menschen haben konnte
erfahrungen gesammelt wo die usa sowie
die übrigen nato länder haben sie mit
einer großen anzahl von kanzler und
flugabwehr raketen ausgestattet im
gleichen sinne trat auch am ersten
januar dieses jahres das gesetz über den
nationalen widerstand kraft mit dem 120
tausend reservisten viele von ihnen mit
kampferfahrung mobilisiert werden
sollten mehr als 200.000 soldaten zu
unterstützen die derzeit in der
ukrainischen armee dienen es versteht
sich von selbst dass ein scheitern an
dieser front katastrophale folgen für
das politische regie von wladimir putin
haben könnte
zweitens könnte eine besetzung nach der
invasion sowohl die russische
staatskassen als auch die streitkräfte
der russischen armee erschöpfen denn um
es klar zu sagen jeder versucht das land
besetzen würde starken widerstand und
viele aktivitäten von aufständischen
gruppen nach sich ziehen jeder kauft
waffen um die russen zu bekämpfen wir
haben viele clubs in denen die leute
jeden tag trainieren miroslav d
ehemaliger kämpfer an der bombast und
widerstand das selbstverständlich von
der nato finanziert ausgebildet und
unterstützt würde da kannst du gift
drauf nehmen das ziel lehre immer den
wirtschaftlichen militärischen und
politischen kosten einer invasion und
besatzung zu maximieren die usa erwägen
einen aufstand zu unterstützen falls
russland in die ukraine einmarschiert
die traurige realität ist das ausland so
viel von der kräne einnehmen kann wie es
will aber es kann sie nicht halten
marlene haring stellvertretende
direktorin des centre des atlantic
council und das alles ich wiederhole
unter der annahme dass die russen nicht
schon während der invasion auf
komplikationen stoßen denn je höher sie
die ziele ihrer invasion stecken würden
desto größer der natürlich auch die
risiken allerdings ist die möglichkeit
in ein wespennest zu stechen nur eines
der risiken welche diese ganze operation
für russland birgt sieht wo ich einfach
mal das folgende an
[Musik]
warum ein wettrennen lostreten dass du
nicht gewinnen kannst
achtet jetzt genau auf die worte von
jens stoltenberg dem nato
generalsekretär
wenn russland also weniger nato an
seinen grenzen haben will hat es genau
das gegenteil erreicht und mehr sie
erneut gewalt gegen die ukraine anwenden
werden sie sogar noch mehr nato an ihren
grenzen erreichen jens stoltenberg nato
generalsekretär bisher hat der kreml die
souveränität der ukraine immer wieder
mit dem vorwand bedroht dass er die
nato-erweiterung bis an die grenzen
russlands eindämmen will nun das
ergebnis einer invasion wird aus drei
gründen zum genauen gegenteil führen
erstens könnte ein einmarsch in die
ukraine mindestens zwei neue länder
schweden uns dazu veranlassen ihre
sicherheit durch den beitritt zur nato
abzusichern zumindest würde die
zusammenarbeit dieser beiden länder mit
der nato gestärkt werden was übrigens
genau das ist was sie in den letzten
jahren getan haben als wir ein
aggressiveres russland zu sehen bekamen
schweden und finnland haben die
bilaterale zusammenarbeit mit den
vereinigten staaten verstärkt schweden
würde sich der bedrohung aus moskau am
karfreitag 2010 bewusst als russische
militärflugzeuge einen groß angelegten
bombenangriff über stockholms
simulierten wir leben aber die direktor
für strategie technologie und
rüstungskontrolle am internationalen
institut für strategische studien sollte
eine militär operation in der ukraine
die mehrheit der nato mitglieder wieder
zusammen bringen vor allem in den mittel
und osteuropäischen länder die sich ohne
zu zögern washington um dem
transatlantischen sicherheits projekt
anschließen würden das ganze ist
sozusagen ein weg das bündnis wieder in
form zu bringen man könnte sagen dass
putin im moment die nato so was die
spinat für puppe ist
und drittens das ist vielleicht der
wichtigste faktor von allen der
einmarsch in die ukraine würde
höchstwahrscheinlich ein riesiges
wettrüsten entlang des neuen eisernen
vorhangs auslösen der sich in osteuropa
bilden würde aber moment mal eiserner
vorhang rüsten wäre das nicht ein
riesiges déjà vu all das hatten wir doch
schon mal und wir alle wissen wie das
ganze für russland bzw damals die
russisch dominierte street union
ausgegangen ist also das ganze ist ein
rennen das russland einfach nicht
gewinnen kann die europäischen länder
haben eine viel leistungsfähigere
wirtschaft und zugang zu
fortschrittlichen technologie und wenn
die sowjetunion mitsamt ihren
okkupierten brüder ländern im ostblock
also vor 30 jahren einen riesigen
wettrüsten mit den usa und westeuropa
erschöpft war kann sich die gleiche
situation heute wiederholen nur eben
frei nach karl marx als farce und
tragödie zugleich
im moment haben boom länder wie polen
estland und schweden bereits der kopf
militärbudgets angekündigt und ihre
streitkräfte wieder aufzubauen und zu
verbessern im falle einer invasion
könntest du dasselbe von der großen
mehrheit der länder in europa erwarten
schon wegen erhöht seine
verteidigungsausgaben um 40 prozent aus
angst vor russland holen will sein
militär angesichts der bedrohung durch
weißrussland und russland aufstocken das
polnische militär hat angekündigt dass
es eine truppenstärke mehr als
verdoppeln will der estnische
verteidigungshaushalt 2022 wetter größte
aller zeiten sein und das sind nur drei
beispiele in zug kommt die verstärkte
entsendung von truppen und ausrüstung
aus ländern wie den usa und
großbritannien mit anderen worten putin
könnte schaffen was washington seit
vielen jahren nicht geschafft hat
europas militärhaushalte auf über 2
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts zu
bringen das fazit wenn es putin absicht
war die nato zu stoppen wäre das
ergebnis einer invasion das genaue
gegenteil und da putin mit seinem
truppenaufmarsch diesen ganzen prozess
bereits zum teil irreversibel in gang
gesetzt hat ist sehr interessant zu
beobachten wie er diesen misserfolg den
nationalistisch orientierten teilen
seiner bevölkerung verkaufen wird und
was du hast wir haben gerade erst
angefangen
dies ist noch lange nicht das ende der
möglichen verluste für russland
russlands großer vorteil der schwinden
könnte
was vielleicht einige nicht wissen auch
während des kalten kriegs hat die
sowjetunion nicht damit aufgehört erdgas
nach westeuropa zu verkaufen die ganze
zeit über war sowohl für das
untergegangene sozialisten imperium als
auch für russland das export eine sehr
wichtige devisenquelle
und vielleicht gerade weil russland die
ganze zeit über ein so zuverlässiger und
billiger lieferant war hatten die
europäischen länder wenig
schwierigkeiten damit ihre abhängigkeit
von russischem gas auf ein rekordniveau
zu steigern ungefähr ein drittel des in
europa verbrauchten gases kommt aus
russland
doch das könnte sich jetzt ändern durch
putins schocktherapie hat ein umdenken
eingesetzt selbst zu zeiten des kalten
krieges nicht zu sehen war die
verkürzungen unter einsatz von erdgas zu
politischen verhandlungen stecken
könnten das ende der europäischen
selbstzufriedenheit einläuten vor allem
wenn nach einem russischen einmarsch in
der ukraine die spannungen zwischen den
beiden seiten des cal ihren würden die
ironie dabei das alles ist ein lang
gehegter wunsch washingtons welches
nicht will dass ihre nato-verbündeten
energie geiseln moskaus sind
[Musik]
und vergesst bitte auch nicht dass die
usa schon lange danach streben ein
großer exporteur von energie also
verflüssigtem erdgas zu werden das dass
die importe aus russland teilweise
ersetzen könnte wir arbeiten mit
regierungen und marktteilnehmer zusammen
um zusätzliche erdgasmengen aus
verschiedenen quellen rund um den globus
nach europa zu liefern gemeinsame
erklärung von joe biden und ursula von
der leyen die unmittelbare folge einer
invasion könnte also das endgültige aus
für den nord stream pipeline und die
dringende suche nach alternativen
energiequellen sein quellen die höchst
wahrscheinlich teurer sind aber
langfristig eine viel bessere sicherheit
bieten so haben zum beispiel länder wie
polen und estland war es bestätigt dass
die neue atomkraftwerke bauen wollen
über die neuen kraft gehen frankreichs
haben wir bereits video gedreht das ich
in der beschreibung unten und oben
rechts verlinken wärme wenn die
europäischen volkswirtschaften also
mittelfristig ernsthaft nach
alternativen zu erdgas aus russland
suchen und sei es auch nur eine
teilversorgung wäre der schlag für die
russische wirtschaft einfach verheerend
denn bedenkt bitte das öl und erdgas
zwei drittel der russischen exporte um
etwa die hälfte der staatseinnahmen
ausmachen stellt euch vor es würden
einfach 50 prozent des russischen
staatshaushalt wegbrechen ein abwegiges
szenario ganz und gar nicht die usa
freuen sich schon darauf das russische
gas und europa mit ihren lng tanker zu
ersetzen gut jetzt werden natürlich
einige anwenden dann verkauften die
russen eben nach china tja dafür ist nur
leider keine ausreichende
transportinfrastruktur und
entsprechender kapazität vorhanden in
einer solchen situation hätte russland
keine andere wahl als riesige
investition zu tätigen um gas zu einem
günstigen preis an die chinesen
verkaufen zu können
wird diese investitionen müssten sie
einen großen teil ihrer mühsam
angesparten die diesen reserven ausgeben
weil hier sehen kriegs war jedoch eher
für die versorgung der eigenen
bevölkerung oder armee benötigen würden
tja eventuell könnte ihn peking das geld
leihen und russland dann vollkommen zu
einem satelliten start machen eine de
facto abtretung des rohstoffreichen
sibiriens an china wäre dann nur noch
eine frage der zeit mit anderen worten
den version könnte am ende einen der
größten politischen und der
zeitwirtschaft zum fünften russlands
beschädigen in zehn jahren könnte die
energielandschaft in europa ganz ganz
anders aussehen als heute und putin weiß
das ganz genau europa gegen china als
gaskunden zu tauschen ist für russland
der weg in die hölle und die arme
ukraine gegen das rohstoffreiche
sibirien würde auch nur ein vollkommen
umnachtet videos tauschen apropos
wirtschaftliche auswirkungen damit wären
wir auch schon wichtigen grund warum der
einmarsch in die ukraine ein kolossaler
fehler sein könnte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sanktionen sanktionen und nochmals
funktionen
im vorliegenden fall läuft das
diplomatische spiel im wesentlichen
folgendermaßen ab moskau droht mit einer
invasion in die ukraine woraufhin
washington und der rest der europäischen
regierungen mit emma der
wirtschaftssanktionen drohen und damit
wären wir schon wieder am anfang denn
für russland heißt es dann gehen sie
direkt in das gefängnis gehen sie nicht
über los und vor allem ziehen sie keine
kohle einer nun ja das ist nichts neues
[Musik]
seit russland die creme annektiert hat
hat die internationale gemeinschaft das
land von wladimir putin mit einer reihe
von sanktionen bestraft im wesentlichen
dreht sich alles um drei arten von
sanktionen finanzsanktionen sanktionen
gegen organischen ideen kreml nahe
stehen und einige beschränkungen für den
kauf von technologie diese strategie
wurde von barack obama eingeführt und
dann von donald trump und joe biden
erweitert
klar es gibt eine gewisse debatte über
die wirksamkeit des sanktionen mit denen
russland bisher bestraft wurde manche
sehen ihn sogar die chance dass das
riesenland autark wird und seine innere
wirtschaft stärkt die wahrheit ist
jedoch dass die russische wirtschaft
seit der verhängung der sanktionen immer
schlechter lief die nackten zahlen lügen
nun mal nicht seit 2014 ist die
russische wirtschaft im durchschnitt nur
noch um 0,3 prozent pro jahr gewachsen
während in anderen schwellenländern die
post richtig abhängen die polnische
wirtschaft zb wuchs im gleichen zeitraum
im schnitt um über 3,5 prozent damit er
die proportion versteht über die ddr
reden ein solcher unterschied
akkumuliert sich mit der zeit zu einer
gewaltigen summe entsprach die leistung
der polnischen volkswirtschaft im jahr
2014 noch 25 prozent der russischen pass
etwa auch dem verhältnis zur
einwohnerzahl entspricht so hat polis
wirtschaftsleistung heute schon 40
prozent der russlands erreicht und ja
ich weiß dass viele von euch jetzt
denken das liegt daran dass dieser
zeitraum mit dem einbruch der
energiepreise zusammenfiel nun ja diese
sind ja mittlerweile wieder stark
gestiegen aber es geht nicht nur um das
wirtschaftswachstum
[Musik]
seit der verabschiedung der sanktionen
gegen die russische wirtschaft ist der
zufluss ausländischer
direktinvestitionen auf weniger als die
hälfte zurückgegangen um die eine
vorstellung davon zu geben das alles
bedeutet dass russland zwischen 2014 und
2019 zum beispiel rund
169 milliarden dollar an produktiven
investitionen verloren hat 169
milliarden dollar die der russischen
wirtschaft jetzt fehlen und nein der
chinese kommt nicht unkompliziert das
denn das ist noch nicht alles hinzu
kommt dass die kapitalmärkte sowohl für
die regierung als auch für alle für
russische unternehmen weitgehend
geschlossen waren was dazu geführt hat
dass sich sowohl die investitionen als
auch die produktivität verschlechtert
haben
das ist einer der gründe warum das
verfügbare einkommen der russen in
diesem zeitraum um mehr als zehn prozent
gesunken ist und warum der wechselkurs
des rubels gegenüber dem dollar um mehr
als 50 prozent gefallen ist das sind
schon fast türkische verhältnisse und
das alles ist nur die spitze des
eisbergs an dem die russische titanic
gerade zerschellt bist du ein konkretes
beispiel okay sie dir mal das folgende
an indonesien algerien und ägypten haben
sich gerade vom erwerb von suchoi su 35
kampfflugzeugen zurückgezogen einem der
juwelen der russischen militär luftfahrt
und einem der wichtigsten bestandteile
des rüstungs portfolios des landes und
die frage lautet natürlich warum haben
sie die bestellung und plötzlich
studiert nun aufgrund der sanktionen
keine russland wichtige komponenten für
die bionik und das radar dieses
flugzeugs nicht mehr importieren was
seine einsatz fähigkeiten erheblich
beeinträchtigt die russischen
rüstungsfirmen können so ihre
vertraglichen verpflichtungen nicht mehr
einhalten und die kunden laufen ihnen
davon dabei muss man sich vor augen
führen jene sanktionen die bisher
verhängt worden sind eher bescheiden und
das könnte sich jetzt ändern gewaltig
ändern
das funktionspaket dass die usa und die
europäische union für den fall einer
invasion russlands in der ukraine
erwägen geht noch viel viel weiter die
rede ist zum beispiel von umfangreichen
exportkontrolle vom ausschluss
russischer banken aus dem
internationalen banken
kommunikationssystem swift über das wir
schon ein video gedreht haben dass ich
euch verlinkten werde vom vollständigen
stopp der finanzierung russische banken
und der russischen regierung oder sogar
neben vielen anderen optionen von so
aggressiven maßnahmen wie diese beiden
droht mit dollar verbot für russische
banken die usa haben erklärt dass die
russischen finanzinstituten den handel
mit dollar untersagen könnten wenn
moskau die ukraine einmarschiert mit
anderen worten es geht nicht nur darum
die russische wirtschaft zu schädigen
sondern vor allem darum ihre weitere
entwicklung total einzufrieren und das
werde erhebliche auswirkungen haben denn
machen wir uns nichts vor auf lange
sicht ist ein land mit weniger
ressourcen dazu verdammt viel weniger
mächtig zu sein in washington weiß man
das und gerade jetzt könnte die perfekte
gelegenheit dazu sein um solche
maßnahmen zu ergreifen das wäre eine
katastrophe ein albtraum für den
heimischen finanzmarkt sergej alexejew
ehemaliger erster stellvertretender
vorsitzender der russischen zentralbank
internationale unternehmen die
investitionen in russland in erwägung
gezogen haben ihre projekte vorerst
eingefroren oder abgesagt die moskauer
börse ist stark gefallen und die
risikoprämie ist in die höhe geschossen
ist sozusagen die ersten folgen von
moskaus riskantes spiel
putin hat es in der ukraine zu weit
getrieben robert gates ehemaliger
verteidigungsminister der usa okay aber
heißt das nun dass damit eine invasion
ausgeschlossen ist nein denn auch wenn
putin sociale absicht nur gewesen wäre
lediglich eine drohkulisse aufzubauen um
stärke zu zeigen seine
verhandlungsposition zu verbessern und
macho punkte bei seine fans zu sammeln
die diplomatische strategie der usa und
der nato hat ihn nun gewissermaßen in
die enge getrieben so dass ihnen nur
drei möglichkeiten übrig bleiben
[Musik]
erstens ein rückzug in die moto2 ein
abkommen zu erreichen das oberflächlich
überzeugend aussieht aber nichts
bemerkenswertes erreicht und
gleichzeitig zugeständnisse an den
westen bedeuten würde oder drittens in
die ukraine einmarschieren
möglicherweise durch eine teil invasion
im nächsten fall könnten die folgen
schrittweise eintreten je nachdem wie
umfangreich die invasion ausfallen würde
dies sicherlich die gleichung die in
moskau nun bewertet und abgewogen wird
falls russland jetzt noch irgendwie
militärisch aktiv werden will muss es
auf eine ablenkung strategie ausweichen
das heißt zum beispiel einen teilrückzug
einleiten um dann in einem unerwarteten
moment an einer unerwarteten stelle
zuzuschlagen
die russischen maßnahmen könnten sich
auch darauf beschränken die anerkennung
der unabhängigkeit der von russischen
kräften kontrollierten gebiete im bass
zu erreichen denn wenn putin wirklich in
die ukraine einmarschieren wollte hätte
er das bereits getan russische truppen
sind schon seit monaten an der front
stationiert es macht sowohl militärisch
als auch langfristig politisch überhaupt
keinen sinn darauf zu warten dass der
gegner seine verteidigung verstärkt und
bedenkt bitte dass dies eine theorie ist
die von der ukrainischen regierung
selbst aufgestellt wurde die immer
wieder betont dass sie keine anzeichen
für eine reale gefahr einer russischen
invasion im land sieht
[Musik]
ja wie dem auch sei alles scheint darauf
hinzudeuten dass washington dieses mal
bereit ist mit harten bandagen zu
kämpfen und sich wohl geradezu wünscht
putin würde in die ukrainische falle der
nato tappen putin ein staatschef der es
gewohnt ist der riskante wetten
einzugehen hat seine siegchancen in
diesem fiasko vielleicht überschätzt das
ergebnis ist nun das was auch immer
moskau tut etwas als szenarien der
wahrscheinliche gewinne die usa sein
werden ein land das bei dieser ganzen
geschichte nichts zu verlieren aber viel
zu gewinnen hat aber auch dies meine
lieben visual politik fans ist nicht in
stein gemeißelt und deswegen werden wir
uns in unserer nächsten video mal die
langfristig und trümpfe russlands in
diesen knallharten spiel ansehen also
stay tuned aber jetzt zeit ihr erst mal
einer reihe glaubt ihr dass putin seine
kräfte überschätzt hat oder glaubt ihr
dass am ende seinen willen durchsetzen
wird was könnte russland von einer
invasion in der ukraine überhaupt haben
und wie sollte die antwort der nato
aussehen wie immer sind auf eure
meinungen diskussionsbeiträge und ideen
schon hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat was ja
gibt uns bitte einen live tiles mit
ihren freunden und vergesst nicht das
abo mit glöckchen um keines unserer
videos mehr zu verpassen natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
spende von euch mit der währungs hälfte
dieses projekt weiterzuführen den link
dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter dem video machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]